kamanzi que vous veniez l'effort de jus
carnet à la morgue de l'hôpital de
sèvres la couleur mais murray certaines
ouvert tôt ce matin c'est gérard
depardieu qui est venu le premier rendre
hommage à son meilleur niveau partager
avec lui sa passion pour leur art il
avait même choisi d'en produire ensemble
d'amis jean carmet n'en manquez pas le
pierre tchernia et tout ceci dit en
passant par guy béart ou bernard fresson
il pleure aujourd'hui l'acteur les aussi
la mini sans faille
c'est un type que je trouve absolument
magnifique ça faisait 30 ans je le
connais et ils avaient une une fidélité
à mi case que je ne connais pas beaucoup
leur métier c'était un biofilm
fanatiques c'était un très fin
connaisseur de grande musique et c'était
face seulement
l'amateur de bonnes bouteilles de bonne
bouffe et de rigolade qu'on connaissait
publiquement chacun pouvait à un moment
donné se reconnaître en lui c'est ça
qu'il avait le formidable
il était vous il est témoin il était
annoncé comme unis dans les années 40
points des vingt ans 18 et lui va par
mois 18 comble ses amis pendant cinq ans
des tas de souvenirs le merveilleux
ensemble c
le corps de jean carmet restera en finir
à riols je sais jusqu'à la messe funèbre
célébré naître